[Musique]
la série des ordres c'est le fruit
finalement de 15 ans d'envie de faire
une série
j'attendais vraiment depuis très très
longtemps sa série ça fait un petit
moment qu'elle l'entête qu'elle m'en
parle j'ai été bercé dans ma jeunesse
par les séries des années 90 qui était
des séries souvent comédie
à la française
bien de ton père si je devais pitié la
série juste une invitation à suivre la
vraie vie de Florence Foresti une
semaine sur deux finalement c'est tout
attends on est parti pour une semaine
entière d'apéro là c'est grasse
évidemment on a essayé de généreux et de
construire des situations amusantes ça
t'allonge la silhouette c'est impeccable
on dirait un gros sac
je voulais situer la série en 2017 on
s'est dit que c'était vraiment la
période où j'ai écrit épilogue j'ai un
spectacle à écrire pour que tu veux que
je fasse une série et ben tu feras les
deux on s'est dit servons-nous de ça
pour montrer ce que c'est que l'écriture
d'un spectacle l'urgence dans laquelle
une artiste peut se trouver que des
vannes de merde à la limite ou des
petites observations du quotidien mais
pas de quoi écrire un spectacle et
comment elle transforme ce qu'elle va
vivre en sketch comme bon oui merci je
sais c'est le mien je sais qu'il est bon
moi j'avais aussi très très envie de
montrer ce que c'était le mal-être d'une
personne de voilà de 45 ans est-ce que
c'était que de vivre avec des troubles
de l'anxiété parce que c'est un peu mal
du siècle je ferai 22h donc je vais
prendre des antidépresseurs toute ma vie
je sais tellement que je suis pas la
seule et je sais qu'on est tellement
nombreux et nombreux à vivre que j'avais
aussi un peu envie de vulgariser ça et
de le détramatiser
moi mon ambition c'est toujours d'être
au plus proche de la réalité que ce soit
dans mes spectacles ou dans ce projet là
je préfère vraiment les choses
naturelles donc si on pouvait
[Musique]
toujours à vouloir prendre des vrais
acteurs qui jouent leurs vrais rôles on
a écrit une super partition puis on
avait envie de déconner à partir du
moment où on s'amuse pour de la comédie
ben ça sent funk
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je travaille
avec Florence j'ai le sentiment qu'elle
a un imaginaire qui est nourrit de sa
fantaisie c'est fantasme et l'OSE les
mettre en scène elle
ose rêver voilà
[Musique]
ça va bien oui